Now we want to actually start looking at the details of how a camera operates.
And we'll be specifically be talking about the details of what happens when
a camera takes a picture.
These are more photographic principles, and all I'm going to be talking about is
what's referred to in the photographic circles as the exposure triangle.
In an exposure triangle, a photographer controls variety of
parameters that let's him or her capture the best image.
The three things that are controlled are, the aperture,
which is the size of the opening that actually let's the light into the sensor.
The shutter speed, which is of course, the,
how fast the shutter opens and closes.
And the ISO, which is the sensitivity of the sensor.
Most of the time,
a photographer basically attempts to optimize all of these three parameters,
that's why this is referred to as an exposure triangle, to get the best picture.
What we're interested in is learning these concepts, because we want to be
able to figure out how we're going to control these in a computational manner.